Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Diäther Bender Erstein auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, alles in Ordnung.
Zuerst werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißt Sie?
Mein Name ist Mark.
Mark.
Mark, ja.
Ok.
Mark Kleinweba.
Kleinweba.
Ok, Kleinweba.
Herr Kleinweba, könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen bestauben?
Mark ist wie Mark, M-A-R-K, Kleinweba.
K-L-E-I-N-W-E-B-E-R.
Ok, Kleinweba. Ja, ich verstehe. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Kleinweba?
Ich bin ungefähr 39.
39, ok. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ja, 1. September 1985.
85. Ok.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 1 Meter 78.
1 Meter 78. Ok. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich bin 4 oder 75.
75. Ok. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Herr Gutierrez.
Ja, Gutierrez. Mit Doppel R.
Mit Doppel R, ok. Gutierrez. Mit I oder Epsilon?
Gutierrez E-S.
Ok, ich verstehe. Alles klar.
Vielen Dank für diese Informationen. Und was für Sie heute sonst? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Herr Kleinweba?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich fühle mich total schlapp.
Ja, richtig bin ich schlapp seit ein paar Tagen. Vielleicht seit 4 Tagen.
Und ich habe auch immer wieder Fieber.
Ja, mal total hoch, dann geht es weg, dann plötzlich kommt es wieder.
Plötzlich kommt es wieder.
Ja, ich habe immer Fieber, manchmal geht es weg, manchmal kommt es zurück.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Ich habe Katerschmerzen.
Alle Muskeln haben Schmerzen.
Und auch alle Kopfschmerzen.
Kopfschmerzen, Muskelschmerzen, Gelenkschmerzen.
Ich fühle mich total schlapp, Frau Doktor. Ich bitte um Sie Hilfe.
Ja, natürlich. Wir werden Ihnen schnell helfen. Herr Kleinweba, bitte machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Als ich Grippe habe, aber das ist ganz anders.
Nicht Grippe, aber wie ich Grippe habe.
Ich habe alle Gelenken und Muskeln, Kopfschmerzen. Ich fühle mich total schlapp.
Ok, haben diese Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten oder denken Sie, es gibt eine bestimmte Auslösung?
Nein, ich habe alle gleich gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Auslösung gibt.
Ok, aber diese Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten?
Plötzlich, vor 4 Tagen plötzlich aufgetreten. Ja, richtig.
Gibt es etwas, das diese Beschwerden verschlecht oder verlindert?
Ja, ich nehme manchmal Paracetamol. Das hilft mir, aber nicht ganz genau helfen.
Sondern ein bisschen hilft mir, dann werde ich ähnliche Beschwerden.
Ok, wie oft haben Sie Paracetamol?
Ich habe 3-4 Mal Paracetamol eingenommen.
Einmal 1 Gramm habe ich eingenommen.
3 mal 500 Milligramm eingenommen, aber hilft mir nicht.
Einmal 5 Milligramm?
500 Milligramm, einmal 1 Gramm. 1000 Milligramm.
Ok, ich verstehe. Haben Sie Ihre Körpertemperatur gemessen?
Ja, heute Morgen war meine Körpertemperatur 39,4.
Heute Morgen habe ich kalt geduscht, dann ein bisschen lindert, aber wieder erhöht.
Ok, haben Sie andere Begleitsymptome, zum Beispiel Neusea, Übelkeit oder Erbrüche?
Ja, habe Übelkeit und gestern habe ich einmal erbrochen.
Wie sah das Erbruch aus?
Ja, es war gestern Abend, nach dem Abendessen, und Inhalt war Abendessen.
Ok, SMS.
Ja, SMS-Reste.
Aber ich habe kaum Appetit, Frau Doktor. Ich möchte seit 3 Tagen nicht essen.
Gestern Abend hatte ich Suppe gegessen und nach dem Abendessen habe ich erbrochen.
Ok, das ist eine unangenehmene Beforderung.
Ja, unangenehm. Ich hatte keine ähnliche Beschwerden.
Es war erst einmal, deswegen habe ich Angst.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, ins Krankenhaus zu kommen.
Und wir werden alle notwendige Untersuchungen und Therapien machen. Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ok, schlafen Sie gut auch?
Ja, seit 2 Tagen kann ich nicht schlafen, Frau Doktor.
Vielleicht wegen Müdigkeit oder Fieber.
Ich schlafe 2 Stunden, dann wache ich auf, dann schlafe ich 1 Stunde, dann wache ich auf.
Das ist immer wieder wiederkehrend. Ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Ok, haben Sie Verdauungsprobleme? Z.B. Zotibrennen, Saueraustausch?
Ich habe keine Zotibrennen, aber mein Darmgeräusch erhöht.
Seit 3 Tagen habe ich Durchfall und Bauchschmerzen.
Ich möchte nichts essen. Ich fühle mich schlaf, erschöpft.
Wie sieht Ihr Durchfall aus?
Wasserig, ich kann sagen.
Haben Sie einen unangenehmen Geruch bemerkt?
Oder haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Geruch ist nicht unangenehm wie Stuhl, aber Blut habe ich auch nicht bemerkt.
Ok, es freut mich.
Haben Sie auch Wasserlassenprobleme?
Ja, das ist verhindert. Ich möchte nicht essen.
Ich kann auch nicht gut trinken, deswegen lasse ich Wasser weniger als bevor.
Haben Sie auch Tarpafusgefühl oder Kriben beim Bein oder Finger?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Bauchschmerzen.
Wie sehr ist der Bauchschmerz?
Der ist sehr stark.
Vielleicht jetzt oder?
Vielleicht 6. Nicht sehr schlimm, aber ich habe immer Kopfschmerzen.
Seit 3 oder 4 Tagen habe ich Kopfschmerzen.
Vielleicht wegen Schlaflosigkeit. Ich fühle mich müde.
Haben Sie in Ihrem Training mit NL5 Schwerden?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung?
Ich habe vergessen, Frau Doktor. Gestern Abend habe ich getrennt.
Ich habe mit Zittern aufgewacht.
Ich habe geschwitzt, als ich geduscht habe.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Ja, ich habe Nachschweiß.
Haben Sie die letzte Zeit ungewöhnlich abgenommen?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, aber vielleicht seit 4 Tagen.
Vermutlich habe ich abgenommen.
Haben Sie Stülfrost?
Ja, ich habe einmal Stülfrost abgenommen. Gestern Abend.
Ich habe Zittern.
Ich verstehe.
Sind Ihnen in der Zeit chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, ich leide unter Asthma, Bronchiade, seit Kindesalt.
Herr Kleinbebau, haben Sie eine Druckgefühl im Bauch bemerkt?
Eine Schwierigkeit?
Ja, ich fühle Belehrungen.
Ich fühle das wie dick.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Druckgefühl habe.
Ich fühle mich ganz oben ab.
Ich fühle die Schwierigkeit.
Ist Ihnen eine Gelbsucht?
Nein, ich habe Hündermeld.
Haben Sie Asthma, Bronchiade und noch etwas?
Nein, ich habe nur Asthma, Bronchiade.
Manchmal benutze ich zwei verschiedene Spray.
Ich habe eine Schleifschule.
Ich benutze zwei verschiedene Spray.
Was ist Ihr Name?
Ich weiß nicht. Manchmal nehme ich eine Tablette, wenn ich Asthma, Bronchiade und Anfall habe.
Bei Bedarf nutze ich.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Als ich im Gymnasium war, hatte ich einen Unfall.
Wegen Unterarmbrüchen wurde ich operiert.
Ich hatte Platten.
Ungefähr 14 Jahre?
Ungefähr 20 Jahre.
Noch etwas?
Nur...
Sind Sie Raucher, Herr Kleinweber?
Ja, ich rauche gerne.
Wie oft rauchen Sie?
Seit 15 Jahren rauche ich ungefähr 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
10 Zigaretten?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal trinke ich Wein, manchmal Bier mit meinen Freunden.
Am Wochenende?
Ein bis zwei Mal.
Ein Glas Wein und ein Flasch Bier.
Ok. Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Das ist eine rütimistische Frage.
Einmal habe ich probiert, als ich jünger war.
Was haben Sie probiert?
Frau Doktor, ich habe etwas geraten und ich hatte dann Schwindel.
Ich habe dann einen Joint geraten.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich spiele gerne Fußball.
Zweimal probieren.
Haben Sie Alergen?
Alergen oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergen, aber ich kann nicht Milch trinken.
Wenn ich trinke, habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen und Blöcken meinen Sie?
Und Durchfall.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, schon.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Bauingenieur in Gambia.
In Gambia?
Ja, ich bin diese Woche zu Besuch gekommen.
Meine Familie zu Besuch.
Ich bin diese Woche zurückgekommen.
Sie leben in Gambia?
Ja, ich lebe in Gambia.
Okay, Gambia.
Ich wohne in einem Container.
Ich bin Bauingenieur. Wir haben eine Baustelle in der Wald.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Prophylaxie gemacht?
Was ist Prophylaxie?
Ich habe einige Tabletten, die ich trüblich getroffen habe.
Ich habe malergenische Erkrankungen und so weiter.
Ich war in Gambia.
Ich habe eine Tablette genommen, aber keine Medikamente.
Jetzt nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Okay, verstehe.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe einen Sohn.
Mein Sohn lebt mit meiner Ex-Frau.
Okay.
Herr Kleine, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerden in Gambia gehabt?
Nein, ich komme nach Deutschland vor einer Woche.
Aber meine Beschwerden beginnen vor vier Tagen.
Gibt es keine Verbindung?
Ist das gefährlich?
Sie haben Angst, ich sehe Ihr Gesicht.
Ist das gefährlich, Frau Dr. Odan?
Nein.
Was habe ich?
Ich denke, Sie haben eine Reiseanalyse.
Ich möchte diese Stelle fragen.
Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Aber ich muss alle Wahlen denken.
Deshalb habe ich diese Fragen gestellt.
Ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Herr Kleine, möchten Sie etwas fragen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, Frau Dr.
Ich denke, ich bedanke mich. Vielen Dank.
Herr Kleine, bitte bleiben Sie in diesem Raum.
Ich komme gleich zu Ihnen.
Okay, Frau Dr.
Vielen Dank.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Natürlich. Bitte.
Mein Name ist Mark Kleimeber.
Kleimeber ist 39 Jahre alt, 1,78 m groß und 75 kg schwer.
Herr Kleimeber steht heute bei uns.
Seit vier Tagen bestehende und genommene Fieber,
Miergussäfargie und Polyatriere vor.
Der Patient hat einen schweren Schmerz.
Er hat einen schweren Prostat.
Er hat eine schwere Durfalle.
Er hat einen Abdominal Schmerz.
Er hat eine Hyperhydrosis.
Die Frage nach ähnlichen vorherigen Beschwerden wurden verneint.
Der Patient hat seine Körpertemperatur zu Hause 39,4 Grad gemessen.
Er hat die Einnahme 3-mal Paracetamol.
Welchen Charakter hat das Fieber?
Die Fieber ist schubweißig.
Manchmal hoch, manchmal weg.
Die Fieber steigt manchmal und sinkt.
Das ist schubweißig.
Welchen Fachbegriff können wir benutzen?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Undüller?
Eine vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Patienten haben eine neue und einmalige Anamnese.
Der Patient berichtete, dass er in Gambia gelebt hat.
Er hat vor einer Woche in Deutschland gekommen.
Er hat keine Prophylaxe angenommen.
Er leidet an Asphabrom Schöle.
Wie ist die vegetative Anamnese?
Die vegetative Anamnese war unauffällig bis auf Schmerz- und Insomni.
Er nimmt zwei Spray und ein Medikament.
Die Dosis der Medikamente sollte geklärt werden.
Er hat seit 50 Jahren 10 Zigaretten pro Tag gebraucht.
Er trinkt gelegentlich ein Glas Wein oder ein Flasche Bier am Wochenende.
Er hat einen Drogenkonsum gefunden.
Der Patient hat in der Gymnasium, im Jugendzeit, einmal einen Joint gebraucht.
Er hat zweimal pro Woche Fußball gespielt.
In der vegetative Anamnese wurde angegeben, dass ihr Vater vor fünf Jahren verstorben ist.
Seine Mutter leidet an Diabetes Melutus Typ 2.
Sie leidet an Neuroentzüge.
Der Patient wurde aufgrund einer Unterarmfraktur vor 20 Jahren eine Operation durchgeführt.
Er ist Bauingenieur und arbeitet als Bauingenieur.
Er ist geschieden und hat einen gesunden Sohn.
Er hat eine Unverträglichkeit mit Symptomen wie Abdominalschmerzen und Diarrhohe.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Anamnistischen ergaben die Leute am Erdhestan auf eine Malaria.
Als Pferanzeiadeagnosen kommen Gastroenteritis, Hepatitis und Meningitis in Betra.
Welche Symptome und Befunde sprechen für eine Malaria?
Die Symptome wie Reisevorgeschichte, schubweisige Fieber und Müdigkeit,
die Abklarung der Beschwerden sollten die vergangenen Malzahmen durchgeführt werden.
So würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Fieber, Hepatocyplenomegel, Nackenstäffigkeit, Hautveränderung,
wie zum Beispiel Ikterus, Exanthem oder Rötung und trockene Schleimhaut vorhanden sind.
Ich messe die Fieber, Bluthochdruck und Herzfrequenz.
Bei der Laboruntersuchung würde ich ein großes Blutbild, SRP, BSG, Lebe- und Nierenwerte, Elektrolyte und Hepatitis-Sterologie bestimmen lassen.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich einen Malaria-Schnalltest, Antigen-Test im Blut veranlassen.
Ich würde eine mikrobiologische Untersuchung durchführen lassen, um das Plasmodium zu sehen.
Und gegebenenfalls ein PSH-Kan machen.
Und ich würde eine Abdomen-Sonographie durchführen, um die Hepatocyplenomegel festzustellen und andere Möglichkeiten auszuschließen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, schlage ich die folgende Therapie vor.
Zuerst würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen, um die weitere Untersuchung durchzuführen und die Behandlung zu optimieren.
Ich würde auch eine Verlösung legen und Analgetika und Antiprätika verabreichen.
Gegen Malaria würde ich eine Medikamentostherapie beginnen.
Welche Therapie meinen Sie?
Ich habe keine mehr Informationen über Malaria-Therapie, aber wir können Kinologon benutzen.
Ich würde auch eine Antimete-Lumefantrin mit der Medikamentostherapie beginnen.
Welches Konsil würden Sie anfordern?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Für diesen Patienten würde ich eine Konzil- oder Intermedizin-Infektiologie beginnen.
Malaria ist eine medikamentostherapie.
Deshalb muss man sich an Malaria melden.
Ich empfehle und habe den Patienten gesagt, dass er im Untersuchungsraum bleiben muss.
Deshalb warten wir auf den Patienten im Untersuchungsraum.
Was würden Sie empfehlen nach der Behandlung?
Der Patient lebt in Gambia.
Gambia ist ein endemischer Bereich für Malaria und andere tropikale Erkrankungen.
Deshalb sollten die Patienten eine Prophylaxe machen.
Die Patienten müssen regelmäßig ihre Medikamente nehmen.
Patienten-Schulung ist sehr wichtig bei diesen Patienten.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Abdominal-Sonographie durchführen.
Können Sie bitte die Abdominal-Sonographie aufklären?
Die Abdominal-Sonographie ist eine non-immagine, schmerzlose Untersuchung.
Mit der Hilfe der Sonographie können wir die inneren Organe beurteilen.
Zum Beispiel die Pancreas, die Nieren oder die Leber.
Wir können mit der Abdominal-Sonographie die Entzündung der Steine, Tümer und der Flüssigkeit beurteilen.
Für diese Untersuchung sollten die Patienten keine Vorbereitung machen.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20-30 Minuten.
Nach der Untersuchung können die Patienten ihre Arbeit normal vornehmen.
Wie machen wir diese Untersuchung?
Wir tragen ein Gel auf der Haut und bewegen den Ultraschallkopf über die Haut, um die Organe sichtbar zu machen.
Die Ultraschallwahlen zeigen uns die Strukturen.
Auf einem Monitor.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Was ist PCR?
PCR?
PCR.
Sie sagen falsch gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt es.
Ich habe falsch gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt SRP.
Was ist SRP?
Nein, ich habe gesagt SRP.
Können Sie uns die Troph-Glutausstrichtung aufklären?
Das ist eine mikroskopische Untersuchung.
Wir nehmen eine dünne Troph in Blut.
Bluttrophen?
Das ist eine dünne Bluttrophen.
Wir haben diese Trophen ausgesucht.
Wir haben diese Trophen mit Gemza, Melden, Malen, diese Bluttrophen mit einem speziellen Malen.
Farbe?
Farbmaterial.
Dann Plasmodium kann sichtbar.
Dann können wir diese Erege unter dem Mikroskop sehen.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen dünnen und dünnen Blutausstrichtungen für Plasmodium?
Das ist ein vieles Unterschied.
Blutausstrichtungen sind dünne Präparate.
Wir sehen weniger Plasmodium in Blutausstrichtungen.
Nein.
Das ist ein vieles Unterschied.
Wir können mit der Dichtroph-Glutausstrichtung Malaria diagnostizieren.
Und wir können mit der Dünntroph-Glutausstrichtung Plasmodium-Type diagnostizieren.
Ja, Type.
Ja, das ist ein vieles Unterschied.
Also können wir sagen, Klassifikation?
Ich bin ja nicht sicher.
Klassifikation, ja. Aber die typische zu bestätigen, sollen wir eine Dünntrophen-Untersuchung machen.
Dann können wir mit der Dichtroph-Glutausstrichtung Plasmodium-Type diagnostizieren.
Ich habe eine Dichtroph-Glutausstrichtung und eine Dünntroph-Glutausstrichtung.
Dichtrophen?
Ja, Dichtroph-Glutausstrichtung.
Wenn man eine Dichtroph-Glutausstrichtung mit Plasmodium-Type diagnostiziert,
dann wird es eine Dichtroph-Glutausstrichtung mit der Dichtroph-Glutausstrichtung machen.
Das ist nicht ganz anders.
Nein.
Dann habe ich es immer falsch gesagt.
Die Infektionshäuser zeigen uns immer, dass es mit einer Kaltdichterung verwendet wird.
Mit einer Kaltdichterung?
Mit einer Kaltdichterung. Man verwendet malaria, also mit einem Zitronen.
Wenn man eine dünne Dichterung macht, dann bezeichnet man den Typen.
Okay, das ist richtig. Jetzt würde ich etwas sagen, aber das ist falsch.
Es gibt so einen Unterschied.
Das ist etwas schreckliches. Ich habe es mir auch mal zuviel zu sagen.
Dichtroph-Glutausstrichtung.
Glutausstrichtung, ja.
Und das Wichtigste hier ist, dass man die Dichterung mit dem Ort, wo man hingeht, bezeichnen kann.
Wir haben heute einen neuen Patienten. Es handelt sich um Mark Kleinweber.
Ich möchte diesen Fall Ihnen vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Herr Kleinweber ist 39 Jahre alt und 1,78 Meter groß und 75 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit fünf Tagen bestehender Sephalgie, Asthenie, Mialgie, Polyarthralgie und Pyrexipho.
Die Symptome sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Eine 5-malige Aufnahme von Paracetamol 1000 Milligramm hat wenige Hälften gebracht.
Er hat eine Verbesserung gebracht.
Er hatte keine anderen Probleme.
Der Patient war letzte Woche in Kumbia.
Die Frage nach gegen Malaria in Funk würde verneint.
In Umfeld oder unter den Anhörigen der Patienten, in Umfeld oder unter den Anhörigen des Patienten gibt es keine Personen mit Anliegen.
Die Symptome würden mit Flatulenz, Tremor, Diore, Noisea, Emesis und Schüttelfruss eingereicht werden.
Der Pyrexie hat 39,5 Grad gemessen.
Die Vaginativen Anamnese sind folgende bekannt.
Sie haben Schmerzbedingte oder Symptomebedingte Inabhidens und Insomnihyperhydrosis.
Er hatte eine Erkrankung, seit Kindesalt, bestehende Asthma.
Er nimmt eine Sprit und eine Tablette.
Die Dosierung und die Filschoff sollten geklagt werden.
Der Patient hatte einen Unfall.
Der Patient wurde mit Platten behandelt.
Die Frage nach Allergien wurde verneint.
Er hatte eine Unfertigkeit gegen Milch, die sich mit Diore und Blasen und Bauchschmerzen äußerte.
Er ist Raucher.
Sie rauchen seit 15 Jahren 10 Zigaretten täglich.
Sie trinken manchmal Wein und Bier.
Sie hat zweimal Druck probiert.
Die Anamnese ist in der Familie.
Sie ist vor drei Jahren an Bronschel-Carsinom gestorben.
Die Mutter hat Diabetes mellitus.
Seine Schwester hat Nieren insuffizienz.
Sie tritt regelmäßig Fussball.
Sie arbeitet als Bauingenieur.
Er ist gestillt und hat einen Sohn.
Ich gehe vom Verdacht auf Malaria aus.
Der Patient hat typische Symptome.
Er hat Fieber, Tränen, Muskelmialgie, Polyarthralgie.
Der Patient hat eine besondere Anamnese.
Er lebt in Kombia.
Er war in Kombia.
Das ist eine besondere Anamnese.
Das ist eine Schipris für Malaria.
Die Diagnose ist aus Gastroenteritis, Hepatitis und Inbetracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich den Patienten vital parametern überwachen.
Dann würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
sollte die Haut verfärbt werden.
Die Lymphen und Knoten werden geschwollen.
Die andere Körperwerte werden verlegt.
Außerdem müssen die Lungen, Herz und Palpeare und Perkuter
die Abdomen unterziehen.
Dann wird die Abwehrspannung
und die Losslastschmerzen verlegt.
Dann wird die Körperwerte unterzogen.
Dann wird die Abwehrspannung
und die Losslastschmerzen verlegt.
Dann würde ich die große Blutbild-SRP
und die gerünen Parameter
und die Elektrolyde bestimmen lassen.
Außerdem würde ich die Sonografie des Abdomens durchführen
um die Abdomenpathologie auszuschließen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Das ist eine spezielle Untersuchung für den Patienten.
Wenn sich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen sollte,
würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Erst würde ich einen Venusszugang legen
und Flüssigkeit, Antiprätika, Anarchistika verabreichen.
Dann würde ich eine Intermedizin
und eine Infektionkonsul anbieten
um meine Therapie zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind,
würde ich den geplanten Untersuchungen fortsetzen.
Herr Kollegen, ich habe eine Frage.
Wie können Sie eine Medikamentierung ausschließen?
Der Patient leidet an Kopfschmerzen und Prexen.
Wenn ich um meine Geizabstuchschilisse
die erste CD-Destattung durchführen würde,
würde ich aber den Patienten Lumbarponktion durchführen.
Können Sie uns Lumbarponktion aufklären?
Ja, ich würde Ihnen Lumbarponktion aufklären.
Lumbarponktion ist eine spezielle Untersuchung
mit der Via Hirn und Wirbel Saule.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns,
die Erkrankung wie Meningitis, Encephalitis
oder andere Probleme zu erkennen.
Die Untersuchung wird im Seitenlage durchgeführt.
Vor der Untersuchung wird ein Stückstelle desinfektisiert
und örtliche Betäubt.
Dann wird eine Nadel ausgeführt.
Die Zwiebeln, die wir von Lumbarponktion ausführen,
sind Lumbarponktion.
Dann wird eine kleine Menge Nieren und Wasser entnommen.
Dann wird die Nieren für die Laboratur untersucht.
Nach der Untersuchung ist die Nieren ungefährlich
und röntgenfrei.
Es gibt aber viele Komplikationen,
zum Beispiel Infektionen, Blutung oder Nierenschaden.
In manchen Fallen können auch andere Untersuchungen
wie MRT oder SST Schadel durchgeführt werden.
Aber das hängt vom Krankbild ab.
Herr Oberarzt.
Ja, unsere Zeit ist um. Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen.